- So, my ego can fuel me,
but it can also destroy me.
But I have the right tools in place and
the right people around me to make sure I,
yeah, I stay grounded.
- Balance.
The duality of it.
- Mmhmm.
So, you know, I know I'm the s--t,
but I know I ain’t s--t.
Feels like it, with the baby grand piano.
- What’s up?
What's up, Taylor?
How are you?
- I'm great.
- You’re well?
- I'm sorry if
this walk-in is not as cool as your,
like, entrances—
- [Laughing] Nah, it’s still
a grand entrance.
- To your fights.
- Yeah, it's still a grand entrance.
Yeah, we tried to mimic it as much as possible.
- That was good.
- But it’s—
- I’m sure they’ll add, like, the background music as well.
- Absolutely.
What song would you play?
- Oooh, right now?
“Cooped Up/Return of the Mack” remix.
It's like a, it’s a dope remix. Yeah.
- “Return of the Mack”—
- And “Cooped Up,” yeah.
- That's quite a pull.
- OK.
- Yeah,
you know, I was about to say, Post Malone’s “Cooped Up,”
and then they juxtapose it with that.
It was beautiful.
- A bit of a mashup.
- Yeah.
- OK, I'mma add it to my playlist.
- OK, so speaking of music, you have never seen
or met me, but I actually have seen you.
I just didn’t meet you.
- Mmhmm.
- I was at Drake's house.
- No way! Fuck off.
- Yeah, OVO Fest.
- Yeah.
- I saw you.
- Damn.
- Yeah.
And I was like, “Wait, is that—”
- At the Embassy.
- Yes! And, OK—
- Yeah.
- How blown away were you about
how that house just transforms?
- I'm literally like—I didn’t
even know we were on the court.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know we were on the
basketball court till
I looked up. Like, my security was like,
“Look up,” and they see the hoops
folded up and then, yeah,
just seeing everyone around.
Even—what’s his name?—
LeBron pulled up on me
and we talked for, like, a minute, 20,
and just—
- Yeah.
- I was just—cuz I was expecting it—
I wasn't expecting to see him.
So, that one kinda got me. Like,
oh, shit, did that just happen? Yeah.
- Yeah. Just chillin’ at the house.
- Yeah, I know. It's crazy.
- Yeah.
So, for you, you’re, first off, at Drake's house—
- Mmhmm.
- And LeBron
James comes up to you at Drake's
house, knows you.
- Mmhmm.
- What does he say?
- It's hard to remember
cuz it was all in a moment.
But we were just sharing love
pretty much for about a minute, 10.
Just, like, showing love and appreciation
and, yeah, admiration for each other's work.
- Yeah.
And, yeah, I just gave him a dap-up
and then kept it moving.
- Yeah.
- Mmhmm.
- Something that I thought was really interesting and cool—
- Yeah.
- About you
being at Drake's
house is I've seen some interviews
where you talk about there
not being a lot of people
in the world that exist that can relate
to the position that you're in.
- Mmhmm.
- And I would think
Drake is one of the few humans that do understand it—
- Yeah.
- On some level.
- On a different level.
- Yeah.
- Like, there's levels to that shit,
you know what I mean?
There's levels to this shit.
Like, there was a, there was a video
I've seen of him
years ago in Melbourne
walking through the airport.
I can understand why he has
Air Drake now.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. Cuz there's levels to this.
- Yeah. You would have to shut down
the entire airport.
- Pretty much. The whole airport was just following him.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah. He can relate, but, again, there’s levels.
- Absolutely.
But, you know,
I do think there's something to, you know,
he is somebody who has always been
inspiring to me as a friend, as an artist,
because he became the things
that he wanted to become.
And it's very hard to do that
and accomplish that, and I'm
sure in some ways, you're like,
“I had a path for myself
that I envisioned—”
- Yup.
- “And up to this point, I have reached it.”
- Mmhmm.
- Do you feel that way?
- I've reached it and exceeded it,
but there's other little things
that I still have to, you know,
attain. Like, different plateaus
I still have to get to.
So, like, even two days ago,
I—what was the name of the building
we were at? The tall—
- [Offscreen:] One Vanderbilt.
- One Vanderbilt. We were up there,
and I met Michael, who was the head
honcho of the whole place.
And as I was there,
I had a moment of, like, gratitude.
Just like, look where I'm at right now.
I could see the whole of New York.
And then there was fireworks
in Central Park.
It was like
it was just right there for me.
- Yeah.
- That's my ego.
But, yeah,
so for me, I was just, like, grateful.
Just a moment of gratitude and just really—
cuz everyone was just watching
cuz there's cameras all around
me and whatnot. I'm just like, man,
this is some cool shit.
- Yeah
- But all right, we keep climbing.
- Absolutely.
And yet you said, so, there's, like,
different levels that you wanna attain.
I almost think about it like a video game,
you know? You're, like, beating the boss.
- I’ve been saying, I’m Player 1!
- Really?
- Oh, like, last time I
flew to New York, to UFC 230,
I said, “I'm Player 1 in this shit
and everyone else is just kinda like
bots in my game.”
But I feel like everyone
should have that view of themselves
cuz you are the Player 1
in your own life.
- Absolutely.
- Mm.
- So, something I've always thought
is interesting, and it's one of the reasons
I'm really excited to
dive into this conversation is
I think
there are two occupations of people:
They can literally do whatever they want.
- Yep.
- And I think it's rappers
and fighters. You almost have no rules.
- Rappers and fighters.
Not no rules,
but I'll tell you one thing. Even, like,
when I walked into the Embassy, right?
I never play on this, but
when a football player walks in a
room, there’s
like, “Oh, shit, there's that guy.”
When a rapper walks in, there’s that guy.
Even in a room full of rappers
and basketball players and football
players, when a fighter walks in a room,
it’s a different vibe.
Cuz men,
we have testosterone and our ego.
Everyone wants to be that guy
that can hold his own.
But the difference is, everyone knows
I can hold my own, but I never play on it.
I'm still very soft.
I'm still very nice and respectful.
But I've seen guys, even rappers,
I've seen them walk around,
you know, like, just—
Like,
you know, like they boutta start some shit.
And I don't walk around with that kind of ego
cuz I feel like—even I posted a clip
yesterday of Jordan Peterson talking about
being capable of being dangerous
but also being able to control it.
Cuz if you're not a dangerous man
and you’re just like, “Oh, you know,
I don't hurt anyone. I'm a nice guy.”
It's like your virtue is useless.
It has no merit because
you have no capability of being dangerous.
So, for me, when I walk in a room—
I notice it as well
when Mike Tyson—amongst fighters,
amongst fighters,
when Mike Tyson walks in a room, everyone
just—boom.
That's Mike Tyson.
- Yeah.
- That's Mike Tyson.
But same thing. He never plays on it.
He's just,
“Hey, man, how you doin’?” Like, you know, he's
real soft and chill, and he's older now.
Maybe when he was younger—
- Mmhmm.
- He’d play on that shit. But me right now—
- I think definitely when he was younger.
- Yeah, yeah.
Oh, no, definitely he did. You know,
walking with a tiger and all that.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, but for me, I'm still,
I just chill. And I could notice
at the Embassy that peoples was—
cuz I didn't really follow basketball
like that.
So, a lot of them were showing love
and whatnot.
There was only one exception was
when, his house, Drake walked through,
and when LeBron was walking around,
then it's like, “Oh, shit, those are greats walkin’ around.”
- Both of them.
- Right, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, were you always able to control it,
and how do you control it?
- That’s a good question.
I wasn't always to control—
when you say “control it,” control
is as in—
- Well, you just referred to, like,
you know, there's something in being
dangerous, but also being able to—
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah, definitely. Martial arts teaches you that.
- Yeah.
- Martial arts,
cuz there's also people who can't control it.
- Mmhmm.
- And it's unfortunate, man,
cuz, like, you know,
I never got to even—
I don't know him like that.
But when I, when I
saw the news about Takeoff,
it hurt me because I was like,
that was senseless.
And that's
because now we're kinda finding out.
We don't know the whole story yet.
So, RIP to Takeoff and I
don't want to speak too much on that.
But whatever his situation, all these
all these young rappers that are dying,
it seems like it just happens to be
our men who aren't emotionally intelligent
or understand their own feelings.
So they just react, you know,
they see some shit.
I have my own story about this.
At the Justin Bieber thing,
a rapper tried to pull up on me
and I just let him know, like, "I'm
not about that life. I'm chillin', bro."
- Mmhmm.
- Like, he a little bit sly.
But yeah, my security, I tell you,
I was just like, "You don't want this."
[Laughing]
- Really? OK.
You don't need to go, like, deep into it.
When you say pull up on you,
it's like, why? Just...
- I think is he knew who
I was and he tried to say like, you know,
"You and my security should spar."
I was like, "What?"
- [Both laughing]
I'mma say that sounds like some
rapper shit, I'll say that.
Yeah, I was like, "What do you mean?"
And then I was like, "Bro,
this is not what you want." Like...
- Yeah.
- And I said it in the nicest way possible,
but I think it's the same thing.
His ego, because he wants to test my gangster.
So I'm like, "I don't need it."
Google me, YouTube me, you'll see it.
- You can watch me do it.
- Exactly.
- Well, separate from that,
what role has ego played in your life?
- Good and bad.
When I was younger, I had to learn how to
manage my ago, because everyone has an ego.
- Yeah.
- But you have to have a healthy ego.
So for me,
I had to learn how to control it
in a sense where I make sure it doesn't,
cuz there's times in my life
when it's overtaking me
and made me look stupid,
and I cringe at those times.
But then I've learned from those and
I make sure I don't let that happen again.
So my ego can fuel me,
but it can also destroy me.
But I have the right tools in place and
the right people around me to make sure I,
Yeah, I stay grounded.
Excuse me.
- Yeah, because I think ego
in some ways can also be a positive tool
because sometimes wanting to protect that
ego and can also,
I think, fuel you forward as well.
- 100 percent. Yeah. Yeah.
- So it's just kind of learning
that, that balance.
- Balance.
The duality of it.
- So, you know, I know I'm the shit,
but I know I ain't shit.
- I'mma steal that.
- Yeah. Nah, straight up.
I know I walk around like I know
who the fuck I am. I know I'm the shit.
But at the same time, when I meet someone
new. Like example, people sometimes get
like, if their friend, their group of five
people, maybe four of them know who I am.
One person doesn't know who I am.
They like, "Oh, I'm sorry.
I don't know who you are."
I'm like, "It's OK." I'm meeting you
for the first time as well.
I like meeting people
who don't know who I am
because they have no preconceived
notion of what they think of me.
They haven't seen me on TV
or maybe they haven't studied me
or watched me in interviews
or shit like that. So they don't,
they get to meet me for the first time
as me, rather than with the idea
of who they think I am.
- Mmhmm.
- I actually, I appreciate that
when people don't know who I am,
I don't appreciate what people know,
who I am, and they pretend not to.
That's another story.
- Yeah, and that's also just weird.
- Yeah. I'm like, "What the fuck?"
I see you. I know you, like, you fu... like why
you pretending like you don't care?
- Yeah.
- I'm like, just be cool. Yeah.
- [Laughs].
Someone told me this quote once,
a long time ago.
They said, "I'm not who I think I am
and I'm not who you think I am.
I'm who I think you think I am."
- Ooo. Break that down.
- Essentially saying that...
- Let me, let me... break that down.
- Sometimes we adapt who
we are based on what we know
that person thinks of us.
So it's almost like a self-fulfilling
prophecy, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, if someone is expecting you to be
Israel Adesanya, you kind of become that.
- I'll tell you a story.
So before my first title
defense in Melbourne,
biggest show ever. That fight week
or the week before that fight week,
I had an epiphany in myself
on my way home from training.
I realized when I meet fans
I don't have to match the energy,
cuz normally—same thing—
I'd meet a fan back then and when they're,
"Oh my God, Israel!" Even if I'm, like,
maybe just cooling at a two, not a 10,
and they come at me with a 10,
I'll raise my energy up to match theirs
just so I can be who they think I am.
I'm like, I'm just chilling, bro.
I'm having a sandwich, I'm doing whatever,
pumping gas.
"I'm such a big fan [grumbling]."
And I'm just like, "Yeah [sighs]."
And I have to raise my energy up
and give them the whole song and dance
just to make sure.
- But then you're like, "Do I have to?" Like, you reach a...
- No, no.
- Yeah.
- I had that epiphany,
and I was just like, "I don't have to."
So now if someone comes at me at a 10.
After that fight week,
so after that fight itself,
I was going back to the airport,
I was going to the airport to go back
home.
And I remember putting out a story saying
like, look,
because I remember I was just tapped out.
All my energy was, my bandwidth
I had none for external shit.
So I said, If you see me on the streets
or if you see me at the airport,
please don't come at me running or yelling
because I'll walk away.
I put that up.
I was just I just don't want to deal
with, like, the energy.
So people actually approached me.
People saw my story,
and they were like, "Hey, Israel.
So I'm a big fan. Would you mind?"
And I'm like, "Oh, yeah, easy ask." Because
they respected my, my, my boundaries.
And that's the thing.
You have to protect your boundaries.
And sometimes fans get entitled and think
like they... I'm like, "I don't give a fuck.
I don't know who you are."
- Right.
- You know who I am, yes.
But this is historic for you.
This is just regular for me.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- And if you don't, like, follow that.
- Oh, you're an asshole.
- There's you're drained, there's burn out.
- No, I'm saying you feel like, "OK,
I have to be." You will get burned out.
- I gotta look after me first.
- [Both:] Yeah
- I look after me first.
- Absolutely.
You know, in a lot of interviews
that I've watched of you,
something that comes up a lot is you,
I guess, not feeling attached to things.
Like, whether that people's
comments of you,
whether it's your title belt.
So what are you attached to?
- What am I attached to? Ooo,
that's a good, man, this is going deep.
- [Both laughing.]
- Welcome to the show!
- What am I attached to?
Yeah, um...
fuck.
This is something I learned from Avatar
as well.
The show, which my nickname comes from.
- Yes, The Airbender, I know.
- Yeah.
When he met Guru Pathik
and he had to learn how to detach himself
from worldly possessions
because he wanted to be able
to control the Avatar state.
There was seven chakras he had to unlock,
and one of them was detachment.
The hardest one for him was to
detach from Katara.
But for me, what am I attached to?
I guess my family, first of all,
because they will always be there.
They've been there before
all of this happened.
They've been there before all this.
So they will always be there.
So I'm attached to them.
My dogs, I keep them with me.
- Love that.
- I'm attached to them.
And my,
uh, my gym,
yes. My training, my training,
my values in that space.
But yeah, any material things?
I'm not really attached
to. Material things
I'm not, I love them.
Don't get me wrong, I like to fucking floss.
I'm light right now
- [Laughing]
- But yeah, I like to flex,
but I'm not attached to those things.
I don't, like,
they don't define me. I make them.
They don't make me.
- Mmhmm,
but I wanna know if you had seven chakras
what they would be?
If you titled them,
or do you already know?
- No.
Everyone has seven chakras.
But if I had seven chakras.
- I'm saying ones that you
personalize, like these are like.
- Oh,
OK, damn OK, that's [clicks teeth].
- But we'll come back to it.
Just ruminate on it.
- Yeah, I'mma have to.
Yeah, OK. Bet. Bet.
- But on that subject of detachment
leads me to obviously there's
this clip that always goes viral of you.
- Yeah.
- Solo shot.
It's just you, and you're saying, "I'm
prepared."
- Oh, yeah, every fight week.
I love that. I love that for me.
- It's you saying, "I'm prepared.
I'm prepared to die."
- Mmhmm.
- Did you mean that?
- Yes. I honestly, people think it's some...
I'm in the fight for my life
in that moment.
OK.
So, the fight itself,
I'll—you need to watch.
I'll send it to you.
But, like, the first round, it's
my title fight, right?
I'm about to become the UFC champion.
The first round, I get rocked,
and it's the first time
I've ever been rocked in a UFC fight.
And then I remember the arena
erupting, like, "Holy s--t, this is it.
The hype train is about to be exposed.
He's about to"—you know how people get.
- And then went back to my corner.
So, I lost that first round,
and I was like, "It's okay, I'll regroup."
I never lost focus.
Second round, I drop him.
Third round, I style on him.
Fourth round, I'm whuppin' his ass.
And then he makes a calculated chess move,
and he hasn't thrown a head
kick the whole fight, and he catches
me. Boom. Hits me in the head,
and I'm there. Takes him about maybe three,
four seconds to realize I'm rocked.
Then he tries to hurt me,
tries to finish me,
and then he took that round.
So, we're 2-2
going into the fifth round,
the last round. I made the
agreement with myself in my own
soul, like,
if this is how I
die, trying to attain this,
what a glorious death.
So, I signed my life away.
I literally—my parents were in the crowd,
my family was in the crowd.
But I signed my life away, like,
if this is how I go, this is how I go,
but what a way to die.
What a way to go out.
But guess what?
If I'm prepared to die,
I'm prepared to kill.
So, in that fifth round, I found a new
level to my fighting spirit that
I never knew was there.
I tapped into it, and I was just—
I looked like I was fresh
from the first round, and I dropped—
It was the most knockdowns
in a title fight.
I dropped him so many times
in that last round,
and I almost finished him at the end.
Like, literally maybe another three seconds,
it would have been over.
But the time ran out, and the referee
pulled me off him and saved him.
- Yeah.
- But, yeah, I meant that.
I really meant that because,
wow, what a glorious
moment that would be.
- So as weird as this is to say,
what I'm kind of gathering is, like,
there was actually some freedom
in being prepared to die.
- Not everybody dies,
but not everybody lives.
Or is it? No, everybody dies,
- Mmhmm.
- That's that bar right there,
cuz a lot of people,
they don't really get to live
because they're too sheltered.
They don't really go
out of their comfort zone.
So, for me, I was forced to live and, yeah,
I showed them how I can live.
- Yeah.
Cuz I mean, you do understand,
like, the weight of that sentence.
- Yeah.
- Like, "I am prepared to die."
- It was—
I didn't plan it.
It was just in the moment.
- Yeah.
- I looked at him, I said, "You're not gonna beat me.
I'm prepared to die."
And I said in my native tongue in Yoruba,
I said, "Ayabiekun,"
and that's like, “The heart of a lion.”
And we just went at it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I took him out then.
- So, then what did it feel like
to get to the other side of that win
and not have to die to do it?
- Yeah.
- For me, just the—when I was, like,
I remember, um, the referee was holding
my hand.
Cuz they hold your hand and are like, "Aaaand new—"
And I was just, like,
"Please don't f--k me over.
I know I won this fight."
And then when they raised my hand—
every time I watch that fight back,
I look at myself.
I'm, like, listening, listening. "Israel."
And my hands went up, and I just had
the sense of, like, yes, thank you.
But then you look at
him, and I remember his face. "Ugh."
And forever I'm gonna be grateful
that, you know—shout out to Kelvin Gastelum.
He's a formidable opponent.
He brought the best out of me, um,
but his head going down, that was just—
I'm glad that wasn't me that night,
cuz to go through that fire
and not get the gold, that—I woulda been fine.
Don't get me wrong,
I'll definitely get over it.
I've gotten over
worse things in my life, but
whenever I see that moment,
I'm always glad my hand got raised.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- There was a sense of relief, like, "Yes,
we did it."
I set a goal for myself
before I even knew I was a great fighter.
I just knew I would be.
Oh, I didn't, you just—
Ali said it: "I'm the greatest.
I said it before I knew I was."
- Yeah.
- You know, and I just knew, like,
there's something in me.
You have it. You just know.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm glad I attained that that day.
And just [clicking tongue].
That's one off the list.
- Mmhmm. And I mean, just iconic moment,
that clip is, like—
- Iconic. Yes.
- Wild.
- Yeah.
- Do you think that just as a fighter,
you have to compartmentalize
a lot in general?
- Yep. My emotions—
a lot of people can't, even in life,
knowing how to, like, compartmentalize
your emotions or just parts of themselves
cuz we're complex creatures.
- Yeah.
- But as a fighter, I do.
Like I said, I can't walk around
looking for
a fight every day cuz a lot of people
like to walk around with that static
or that bravado that the idea
of what people think they are,
they got to keep that up.
Like,
I don't even have my nails done right now.
Like, I'mma get my nails done before presser.
Yeah, coz I normally got—
- It's great that you get manicures.
Everyone should.
- I know. I'm, like, they sexy. Well, first I got—
They're called French tips, but I call them
drip tips. They're not even made in France,
but, like, they look sexy.
I mean, I kept on getting distracted
when I first got them.
I was like, "These are f--king clean."
But, yeah.
So, um, for me, I just,
I don't care what people think of me.
Even when I was doing "The Pivot"
the other day, homeboy—what's his name?
Channing was like,
you know, "You ain't got your pearls on."
He's trying to bag on me.
But I was like,
"They look good on black skin.
I'm like,
"What the f--k are you talking about?"
And he's, like, "Yeah, but,
you know, like, why pearls?"
I'm like, "Well,
diamonds are a girl's best friend, right?"
- Mmhmm.
- That's the saying. I'm like,
"I see a lot of rappers rocking diamonds."
- Yeah.
- Who's the one telling—
who makes these rules up?
Who makes these? It's society.
- They're just arbitrary.
- So, I'm like
"Yeah, I"—like I said,
Player 1. I am—when you play a game,
you know, you design your character,
attributes and whatnot.
That's what I do in this life.
This is all simulation or whatever.
- Mmhmm.
So, we're in "The Sims,"
and I'm designing my character
the way I want it.
- Yeah.
- And I play the game how I want to play it.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah.
- For sure.
And I've also been on "The Pivot,"
and Channing also got on me. Story for a different day, but—
- That's his thing. That's his thing.
- You're not alone.
You talk a lot about this,
Like, TikTok era that we're in, that
people have very quick attention spans.
[Snaps]
And you being aware of that—
- Hold up. Pause, pause, pause. Hello!
- It's a party in the house.
- Quiet on the set!
- You're hired.
- I've been around. I know that—
I know how everything works. Yeah.
We didn't even do the f--king [clapping] for sync.
You do that?
- We did. You miss—at the end.
We'll have you do another one.
- OK. Yeah, yeah, OK. I was, like, man.
- Yes, just for us.
- Easy.
- We'll have you do the slate.
- Um, we are,
you know, we're in his house.
So, it's all the friends, all the people.
Lot of men running around here.
- Mmhmm.
- Um, but yes.
- Testosterone City. [Inhales]
- It is. I feel it.
- You can smell it.
- You feel it right
when you pull up.
- It's all the gym gear.
That's what it is. You're like [inhaling]
"Mmm."
- You know, things layin’ around. It's, like, I love it,
I'm into it.
Um, but yes, you talk about the attention span
and all of that,
and you being aware of that,
what can you do to keep people's
attention?
- Hmm.
I know how to. I know how to play this game,
Like, even before.
So, all my social media,
I have never bought followers,
I've never boosted posts,
nothing like that.
I know a lot of people
who have. You know who you are.
I know people who fugazi that shit.
But for me, even back in China,
I was editing my own videos,
doing my own highlights,
putting it out there. Cuz I just knew
how to farm people's attention.
I got lazy actually, maybe the last year
and a bit cuz I—I don't know, like,
once I crossed, like, a million, I was like,
OK, it wasn't it. It didn't really excite me.
So I realized I can't just stop there.
I need to keep farming and keep working.
It's part of the job.
- Mmhmm.
- A lot of people don't
really take that into consideration.
They have people organize
the social media and whatnot.
But yeah,
I know how to keep people's attention.
I can keep people entertained,
but I'm not going to do it,
I guess, in the way they want me to.
- Right.
- I'll do it my way.
Because if I do it my way,
those who fuck with me, will fuck with me.
And they'll come through.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, build it, and they'll come.
- Yeah.
And you really only want the people there
that are actually genuinely do fuck with you.
- Exactly. Yeah.
- So this is fascinating to me.
I read that you have, like,
a documentarian that follows you.
- Yeah.
- A guy named Jeff.
- A guy Jeff.
- So you have to decide to let
someone essentially record
good moments, bad moments,
embarrassing moments, things
you didn't really want anyone to ever see.
- Mmhmm.
- How do you get comfortable doing that,
and what's off-limits?
- Experience. Experience for me.
For me, it's pretty much like,
I think he's been following me
or documenting me since 2015.
- Wow.
- That was on and off.
But then maybe he moved to New Zealand
three years ago. And a little bit
more in-depth. And the documentary actually
is almost finished.
I've seen, like, the rough cut twice.
Honestly,
even if I wasn't the protagonist in it,
I feel like men need to watch this
because even my coach Eugene
got, like, raw and emotional and... Cuz
I'm like, bro, who, you gonna tell me what,
I'm a softie.
I'm like,
yeah, I am soft, but I'll whip your ass.
Like, that's the duality again.
Like,
you can't bag on me for being a softie
cuz you know exactly what I do to you.
- Mmhmm.
- But yeah, I feel like men need to watch this
movie because it just shows
that we can tap into
our emotions
and our natural human functions.
Like, even crying. Like, there's cortisol
that's released through tears.
And after I have, like, a big cry
sometimes I feel much better.
Like, literally, physiologically,
I feel relaxed.
[Sighing]
Glad I got that off my chest. Cuz a
lot of men just hold that shit in.
- Yeah.
- And you tell little boys,
you see that in the culture, like,
you know, ah, come on, buckle up.
You don't cry. You know, men don't cry.
And it's like,
these are kids. These are babies.
Let them fucking express.
- Yeah.
- You tell them to just bottle that shit up.
And then when they grow up,
you know, all that shit.
And then you,
I see a lot of domestic
violence happening.
I see a lot of bad shit happening
because men don't know how to tap
into that side of themselves.
And me expressing myself authentically
and showing people that I guess it's—
it's, like, a cliche, it's OK.
But it's like, nah,
I'm just showing you how it is.
And once you see the doco, you'll
understand
because I'm practicing what I preach.
- Yeah.
It's beautiful.
- Last big cry?
- And what's off-limits?
Oh, I didn't say.
- Yeah.
- What's off-limits for me is my, like,
I've honored my parents. After the Gastelum fight,
I honored them in the cage.
I put the belt down in front of them.
Oh, no, no. After my, that was for Eugene, sorry.
I honored Eugene first
after the Gastelum fight.
My first title defense in Melbourne
when I fought Robert, I honored my parents.
But now I've kind of pulled them back
a little bit away from the spotlight.
And then when I have a family,
they're not going to be on this
cuz I don't want them...
I'm Israel Adesanya.
- Mmhmm.
- The bar has been set.
I've talked to some other great men
in my position who have kids,
and same thing.
They're not trying to, like,
you know, shelter
their kid from the world,
but they're making sure
that their kid doesn't have this on,
I guess, like, unrealistic expectation
they have to meet up, live up to.
- Mmhmm.
- You know what I mean?
They need to enjoy their life
as just themselves.
So when I have kids, they're not
going to be on your, you'll never see them.
- Yeah.
- People in my life will see them.
But I don't want people,
maybe they're at school,
Like: "Oh, you're Adesanya's kid.
Yo, can I get a photo?"
I'm like, nah, fuck that.
Like, when I have kids, yeah,
they gonna be off-limits.
- Yeah.
You want them to have some, like, autonomy
- in their lives.
- My private life is not for sale
cuz I know this world.
I've seen it
too many times in the tabloids.
They'll take it away from you.
Give them too much.
I give people enough, a little bit,
but I don't give them too much
of my private life.
Cuz if you give them enough,
they'll get involved emotionally.
And people just think, like, they can,
yeah. You see shit like that.
Like, when I see you, like, the shaderoom
posting shit with these people
and they're having arguments online,
I'm like,
- Yeah.
- you're in the same house.
- Right.
- Talk to each other.
Why you having arguments with an audience?
Like, it's cringe to me. I'm like,
this is something that you guys need
to sort out between yourselves.
Yeah, could never be me.
Mm-mm.
- Yeah.
Now, I mean, I also think social media
has normalized, like, a lot of just weirdo
things
- Tacky.
- Yeah.
-Tacky as fuck, man.
- that are not real.
You said that crying has been therapeutic
for you to be able to just let it all out
sometimes.
- Yeah.
- What was your last big cry?
- Ooh, it was definitely this camp.
It was definitely this camp.
Cuz Eugene decided to fucking
shake the snow, like, that's not kosher.
He shook the snow globe a little bit on all of us.
He kicked us up the ass.
But the energy he did it with,
it was just, like, I was like,
I'm already doing my best.
Like, I can do more,
yeah. But, like, the energy he did it with
was just kind of upsetting.
And he was really rough. And,
like, some tough love.
And there's something
he said—it's family business—that, yeah,
upset me at the gym.
So I just, after I finished training, packed
my gear, and I drove home. And I,
yeah, I expressed in the car.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah.
And I think I might have called my mum.
And I just cried.
Yeah.
But it's good to get it out.
Cuz after I did, my mum
let me know it's OK.
And yeah, I felt much better.
- Yeah.
So just out of curiosity—
I know it's family business;
I'm not asking what he said—but did it
upset you because you felt it was true?
Did it upset you...
- You're good.
Hmm. Did it upset me because I felt it was true?
Mm, I've not, it upset me because I was like,
you know me. Like,
I'm never going to change.
I'm still me.
I think sometimes he still thinks,
oh, he's just, it's like a, he's making sure
I'm still me.
So I'm like, I'm, I've not changed
Cuz I,
if I was going to change
and switch up and think, I'm...
Like, I said, I know I'm the shit,
but I know I ain't shit.
But if I was going to walk around
and think I'm the man all the time, like,
that would have happened a long time ago.
So I was just like, nah, you know me.
Why you think I'm,
you need to do this to, like, fucking,
clip my wings or something? I don't know.
- Yeah.
- But I have to think about it.
Maybe, was it true what he was saying?
I have to think about it.
- OK.
I'm only saying that
cuz I know—
- I know. Play devil's advocate.
- Sometimes, you know, when,
yeah. I wanted to know.
And also sometimes I think the things
that make us the most mad are
things where like,
- Yeah, a little bit of truth in them.
- damn I low-key
know what they meant.
- Yeah. Yep.
- But, like, you not supposed to say it.
- He might, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I don't know. I don't know. So I have to think about it.
- I can't just answer right now.
- So that's a good homework for me to do.
I'll get back to you on that.
- No, someone once said to me that,
like, when you're mad or sad,
you should actually critically
think about why.
- Yep.
- So I always try to ask myself, like,
why I actually feel that way
as opposed to, like, the very surface
level of, like, oh, well,
he said something to me. It was mean.
Well, it's like, well, why was it mean?
- Yeah.
I could just dismiss it,
like, oh, they're a hater or whatever.
- Yeah.
- But it's like, nah, sometimes the way, even me,
when someone makes me feel
a certain way or anything,
it speaks more about me
than it does about that person.
- Yeah.
- So for me, I know for a fact
when I dress the way I dress or I dance
the way I dance, when—and I like to dress
the way I dress just cuz it
pisses people off.
- Yeah.
- It pisses a lot of people off.
So, and they trying to bag on me for that.
But I'm like, you realize
that says more about you
than it does about me?
- Right.
- The fact that you have this visceral
reaction to nothing that involves you.
But you, like,
oh, why is you fucking [growling],
why is you wearing those? Or why...
I'm like, Crocs even.
They're like, "Oh those are for kids.
Why are you wearing those?
You're a 33-year-old."
I'm like, why do you care? Why do
you give a fuck what someone else—
- [Laughing]
And also they're comfortable.
- Yeah.
If I put on a
sportswear, I'll chase your ass down.
Yeah.
- Everyone at Crocs is like, all right,
we need to sponsor him now.
He loves us.
- Yeah.
- OK, so something that is always super
interesting to me about fighters
is you guys are incredibly confident.
I think confidence
is just beaming off of you.
- Yes.
- And I have never seen a fighter say
or act like they're defeated
even when they lose.
So what is your relationship,
like, with that word
defeat?
- Defeat.
One of my
best friends,
one of my guys who is
no longer with us, Jamie van der Kuijl, VDK,
he had this quote.
He said, "I've lost many times,
but I remain undefeated."
And that stuck with me for life.
Because when you when you say
that, defeat is a state of mind.
Cuz I—so I went up to 205.
That's the weight class above me,
right?
I went up to try and get the 205
belt. And good fight, close fight.
But I felt I lost the fight.
Some people had me winning.
I felt I lost the fight.
But I think people were quite surprised.
I was like, well, dare to be great. I tried.
I failed that one. But it's all right.
I'll get him next time.
So I lost the fight.
But I wasn't defeated.
- Mmhmm.
- I wasn't defeated.
Even, he didn't...
Yeah,
he was meant to do all this shit to me.
People were saying.
He didn't really get it done.
But he still won the fight.
If he had knocked me out,
I still would have had the same mentality.
- Yeah.
- And the same thing even with this guy
that I'm fighting next weekend.
He's knocked me
out in the previous, like, five years ago
in kickboxing. But same again.
I never, look at me now.
- Mmhmm.
- He's beaten me supposedly twice,
but look at me now. I'm the one winning.
And he kept on trying to get at me
because I'm doing so much
better than him in life.
- Yeah. So defeat isn't, like, a thing that
happens to you. It's something you feel.
- You accept this.
Yeah, you accept defeat. Some people, in life,
there's times in life
I felt defeated away from fighting.
- Yeah.
- Life kicked my ass.
Like, 2013 was my great depression.
I remember that year. It was,
I was, that's when I moved to China.
I quit my job September 4th, 2013.
That was my last 9 to 5.
September 5th,
I was on a plane to China.
And I tried to quit that job
three times prior.
But that time I got it right, and I set
everything up so I can
just [clapping] out of there.
But it was because
life made me really uncomfortable.
Life put me in a place that I...
Yeah, it was really bad.
So I was defeated.
But then I, again, you can dust yourself
up, rise back up and get what's yours.
- How did you get out of that place?
- Mentality.
The mentality I had. And for me,
the key people around me. The key people
I had around me as well. But I think it
was just my spirit, my fighting spirit.
And also a lot of prayers
from mom and dad, my spiritual warriors.
You know? Yeah, they help me a lot.
- I love that.
- Mm.
- OK, I am going to say some words.
- All right, shoot.
- And I want you to tell me either
the role they play in your life,
- Mmhmm.
- what emotion
you know, elicits, like, what happens
when you hear them.
OK?
- OK.
- Revenge.
- ♪♪♪ Looking for revenge. ♪♪♪
- All summer 16.
- Eh, on November 12th, eh.
On November 12th, uh.
Revenge. Revenge.
There's so many things about revenge.
And it's not always the best option.
There's a time for revenge.
I never went looking for this fight.
Like I said,
- Mmhmm.
- I let it go a long time ago.
I'm just living my life, being great.
And then life presented me
with this opportunity.
- Mmhmm.
- Cuz I was patient,
and I didn't go looking for it.
It's like, here. Now it's yours.
Take it. I'm like, aight.
So now it's time for revenge.
But you can't go looking for it
constantly.
I don't think, like, that's the best thing.
Cuz, again, you're in that mindset.
You might
spray the wrong people
sometimes if you're in that mindset
all the time. Not,
you know, like, physically
but, like, emotionally
and snap at the wrong people.
Cuz I know people who stay
in that mindset, and they just, like,
they burn bridges a lot.
- Yeah.
- A lot.
So, yeah, revenge plays a good
role in life, but you have to know when to
look for revenge.
And again, what did I say?
I said: God forgives. I don't.
The Lord said vengeance is mine.
And I'm like, yeah, me too.
And now it's mine.
- I love it.
You pull quotables.
- I'm just freestyling.
- Yeah.
OK, next word.
- Violence.
Violence
isn't always the answer.
But again, there's a time for violence.
And like I said,
you have to be capable of violence
as a person. Not just as a man.
I feel like as a person. But as a man,
you have to be capable of violence.
It's better to be a warrior
in a garden than a gardener in a war.
Cuz, you know, when
it's time to get down, to get busy,
I need to know I can take care of me
and my own, you know?
So violence is necessary.
Every man needs to learn martial arts.
They need to put it in school
and teach them how to meditate as well.
So you're capable of violence,
but you know how to, you know, keep cool.
Yeah.
- I like,
I see, like, in a lot of your interviews,
you're like, I know how to speak violence.
- I can.
- Yeah.
- Like, also there's times in my life
when people have wronged me in the worst way,
and I can get dark on them.
- Mmhmm.
- I've said this.
There's no, people try and be virtuous.
Like I said, they say, "I'm a good person."
I'm like, you're not virtuous.
You're only a good person
cuz you have to be.
Cuz you can't do shit.
- Mmhmm.
- It means nothing that you're a "good person"
cuz you're weak. That's why.
But if you're a violent person like myself,
and I choose to be a good person to you,
it means something.
Cuz I could destroy you.
- Mmhmm.
- It's different.
So if
I'm violent, capable of violence,
but I'm virtuous in my goodness,
then that's different.
So I say there's no good or bad people.
People are just capable of great
good or great evil.
We're human beings.
There's a duality.
So there's times I've been evil,
but there's a lot of times I'm good.
- OK, next word.
- Mmhmm?
- Perfection.
- Eh, not me.
I chase it in martial arts.
I know I'll never attain it.
But it's
the pursuit of perfection in my craft.
- Yeah.
- In my artwork. In the way I live.
But I just know perfection is,
I will never attain it.
I never—cuz you grow up with that
kind of pressure a little bit sometimes.
And certain, even people who are
always expecting that from me when I fight.
Like, "He's gonna be perfect," this and that.
But I'm like, fuck your expectations.
- Mmhmm.
- It's about my expectations.
So, you can keep that over.
[Burping]
Excuse me.
You can keep that over there.
- Yep. Last word.
- Mmhmm?
- Alex Pereira.
Mm, let me see.
He's got a head like,
you know, those Easter Island statues?
- I do.
- Yeah. They call him Hands of Stone,
but he's got a head of stone as well.
And I know this, but I can break blocks.
Yeah, I break bricks now.
- Mmhmm.
You know, this is going to be a fun fight.
And there's a lot to dive into with it.
So I think since we're here,
we might as well just start.
- [Whooshing sound]
- For you,
- Mmhmm?
- what does this fight represent
specifically?
- For me,
what does it represent?
A chance to rewrite history.
A chance to, I can't
change the past.
It's happened.
That is the past. I've let it go.
But now there's an opportunity
now to rewrite history for the future.
This is my chance.
And that's why I've done it.
Every single thing in my power
in this camp to make sure that happens.
And I'm so confident. So much confidence
that my wrestling coach is like,
"Yo, let's go play table
tennis. I'll humble you real quick."
- [Laughing]
- Cuz they can see,
they can see—oh, yesterday
after I trained, Tim, how was I?
Exactly.
- Tim says...
- Savage.
And I don't want to say too much
cuz people talk.
You supposed to hype a fight up.
You think I'm coming in
like,
I might do all right.
You know what I'm saying?
Nah, Imma fuck this guy up.
- Yeah.
- But I don't want to say too much
cuz he's got bragging rights.
- Mmhmm.
- And I understand that.
So I'm like, you know what,
let him think whatever he wants.
Let him, it's all good.
Eh, easy as, you know.
- So with that being said
then, what is the difference,
like, in mental preparation
when you're getting ready to face
somebody who has beaten you?
Cuz I know you say you let it go,
but mentally, how do you prepare?
- Like I said, a lot of internal work
I've done over the years is just,
it gives
me experience to be able to do that.
Again, I'm not reacting to his probes.
He's been trying so hard to probe me.
I'm like, eh.
Try harder.
- Yeah.
- You know?
But then again, when it's time to work,
I know what I do.
When I get busy, I get busy.
- Mmhmm.
But right now, I'm like,
he's got bragging rights.
He can talk all the shit he wants.
I don't even have to try
and intimidate him.
He's not very,
it doesn't work on him. So same with me.
I don't know
if he's going to try and intimidate me.
Good luck.
This doesn't work on me.
- Mmhmm.
- But I hope
he thinks he's gonna walk in there
and walk through me.
I hope he thinks that cuz
he's going to be in for a rude awakening.
But again, maybe not.
Maybe I might just fucking,
I don't know, run around and
and then try and escape him
and maybe jump out of the cage.
Who knows? But hey, stay true.
That's why you got to watch the fight.
You'll see.
- Yes.
So, OK.
I primarily cover a lot of MMA and NFL.
And something that is always—
- Am I the first MMA guy?
- Yes. Well, we had, you were the first.
We had Jake Paul.
- Oh, nah, he does boxing. That's my dog, though.
- Yes.
- That's my dog.
- One thing
that is always very clear to me when I'm
watching games is there's always, like,
one team that cares about the matchup
a bit more than the other.
And I'm not saying they care about it
in the way
that's gonna, like, make them win.
- OK.
- I'm saying they feel like winning
will mean more to them.
- Mmhmm.
- Do you feel like in this
there is somebody who
winning is gonna be a bit more important?
OK, explain.
- Me.
Cuz, again, rewrite history.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, this guy's beaten me.
I've fucking pretty much cleaned out
the middleweight division, my division.
That's why I went up to try and capture
the light heavyweight belt.
But I'm going to lap the division again.
I'm lapping them right now.
I've cleared the way.
So, without me, he wouldn't be here.
- Yeah.
- He would've got exposed a long time ago.
So he's pretty much blessed
to be in this opportunity.
So I'm happy to, yeah, expose him
when it's time.
But right now, I'm like, let people
watch the highlights.
Let them think
what they want to think. And...
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah. Time will tell.
- What have you learned about yourself
in preparation for this fight?
- Hmm. In the preparation for this fight...
Hmm, what have I learned, what's something—
I already knew I'm a savage.
I knew the levels I can go.
My mental capability to endure.
Yeah, I don't want to go too much into it,
but there's a lot of stuff that happens.
You know, sometimes outside of the gym,
sometimes in the gym.
But yeah.
Police. Why is the police here?
Sorry.
- No, it's OK.
- I'm Black, you know.
- Oh, I get it.
I'm like, police are here?
- What the fuck are they here for?
But yeah, uh, yeah, just
my capacity to endure cuz,
yeah.
Heavy is the head that wears the crown.
I got a big head,
so I got a big crown.
- Yeah.
- And I can handle it.
And I think, you know,
enduring things, that really is just, OK,
who is going to outlast the other?
And that's most of everything.
So...
- You watch.
- Yeah.
- I'll be watching. I'm ready.
- Yeah, like,
I know for a fact I can outlast him.
- Yeah.
- So this is where
that fortitude comes.
- Mmhmm.
- That mental fortitude.
And knowing who I am,
knowing my spirit, my fighting spirit.
I'm not underestimating him.
They tell you, "Never underestimate anyone."
But they forget to tell you,
"Never overestimate them."
- No, fear makes the wolf bigger than he is.
- Yeah.
- I always say that.
- A lot of people just, they get,
I'll show you a little secret right now.
Look at this.
This is my background. This is my background
right now on my lockscreen.
But then when you open it...hold up.
- Wow.
- Shh.
- And so you see that every day?
- Yeah. I did something last night
that kind of made me,
I did, like, a little thing.
I was like, huh.
So then now I changed it last night.
So that way
when I opened this, I'm just like,
interesting.
- Yeah.
- Just to put it back in my psyche.
Just to put it in my forefront
whenever I open my phone. Just to know.
Just so I know.
- Yeah. What's possible.
- Yeah.
- I can make him bleed.
And I already said I'm gonna make this
a horror movie. But hey, man,
sometimes people sleep
through horror movies, so
stay tuned,
bring a pillow and enjoy the show.
- [Laughing] No, I love that.
OK,
so generally,
not just focused on this fight,
I want you to fill in the blank for me,
OK?
I am the most blank fighter.
- Ooh. I am the most
intelligent fighter. Yeah.
- Explain.
- I think the way I look at the game.
But that's me,
I'm being biased because I'm me
and I think I'm really smart.
But also I'm the most creative fighter.
I've, in my own sense, changed the game.
But it's not just me, it's my team.
The way we played the striking game,
a lot of people tried to copy
some of the things we do,
but they don't understand the—
you might copy the recipe,
but the sauce ain’t the same.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- But, um, yeah, I just think different,
and I actually mean that,
and I move different.
Even the way, the way I dance, you know?
People understand,
like, I actually move different.
You know, I'm not, I'm
not the same as everyone else.
My rhythm,
my timing, my creativity is next level.
- Mhmm.
- Yeah.
- I love that. OK,
so most intelligent and most creative.
- Yeah.
- OK.
A couple more from me
before we go to fan questions.
And these are literally—
- Ooh, fan questions. Oh, yeah, we’re live right now. Mwah.
- Yes, we are.
They're all watching.
- Sup, guys?
- And this
is just literally because I'm curious.
- Yeah? OK, here we go.
- Your first fight
before you were a fighter.
So, you're fighting, and probably
have no business to be fighting,
but you're fighting.
- Yeah.
- What was your first fight
and did you win?
- Before I was a fighter.
OK. I fought back in Nigeria.
I definitely had a few scraps.
But I'm trying to think. OK,
one of my first fights,
my first fight in New Zealand, right?
So, what—I've always said this, I didn't know
I was Black till I moved to New Zealand.
I don't mean that in like the sense
I, you know, my skin tone.
But I just didn't realize
it was a problem to be Black
until I was removed from Nigeria,
from the continent of Africa,
and I was placed in this foreign land
and people were making fun of me
for my skin tone.
- Mhmm.
- And they made me feel s--t about it.
And I was like, “What is it?
What did I do?”
So this one kid kept on
riding by my house through the weekend
because he found out
where I live—riding by on his BMX.
He kept on saying,
“Go back to your country, Blackanese.”
Funny enough,
I remember his name.
And I was just like,
“I don't—I know this kid from school,
I've seen him around,”
but like, cuz he was giving me s--t at school,
but I didn't know—like
he was riding by my house.
- Wow.
- And then—
- Just to bully you?
- Yeah, just talk s--t.
But then that Monday,
after
the first interval, he walks up to me
and goes, “What’s up
black boy?” Boom, and pushes me.
And he was shorter than me, and I was a short ass
back then, I was a short ass.
But then I got up and I whooped his ass.
Threw him towards K Block, beat him up,
threw him to—and I'm crying the whole time.
I'm beating him up on B Block, K
Block again, and everyone's watching.
And then one of the teacher stops it,
and I just like, "Leave me alone!”
And I run away and go hide
somewhere in the field. And, yeah—
but he definitely never f--k with me
after that again.
- Yeah. [Laughing]
I'm sure no one did, if you’re just
throwing him back in.
- Yeah. Oh no, I threw him, and I’m swinging on him,
crying and swearing at him
in my, in my language.
Yeah, it was—I remember that.
Yeah.
- Well, cuz to me,
that's the interesting thing
about being a fighter is I'm like,
there has to be like a point in your life
where you say,
“Hey, I'd be good at fighting.”
And I just wonder—
- What point that was?
- Yeah.
When you know, oh, the thing
I'm good at is f--cking people up.
- Yeah.
- Like, what is that? [Laughing]
- The moment I had that—
so dancing was my, my proper first passion.
And I always thought like
I would be on tour with all these guys
and being a backup dancer or a choreographer.
But then there came a crossroads
in my life where I was like,
“I'm a great dancer, but
I'm so good at f--king people up.”
I'm like, “But I can always dance,
but I may end up in jail
if I keep just f--king people up randomly.”
So I decided to take this as a career.
So that was a crossroads.
But, yeah, I think just watching
greats like Anderson
Silva, Muhammad Ali, Prince Naseem,
and all of a sudden, “You know what?
This is my—this the path I'm going to take.”
- Yeah. How,
if you were describing it
to somebody in great detail...
- Mhmm.
- how does it feel to punch someone?
- Oh.
- And how does it feel to be punched?
- Being punched doesn't actually hurt
like you think, cuz adrenaline's going.
And it only if it, if it rattles
your brain, then you can get rocked.
Or if it shuts you off,
you get knocked out. But being punched,
I don't fear being punched.
You know, I don't like being punched.
Nah, but um—
Yeah. At least there’s—
- But punching someone.
- Yeah, punching someone,
knocking someone out,
sometimes it's the punch
you don't really try
and knock them out with that
just turns them off, and you’d be surprised.
It feels like nothing.
It feels like you're punching through air
sometimes.
Yeah. But then—I'm trying to think.
Example, the Whittaker shot.
When I cracked him—boom.
That one,
It felt like I just went through him.
Same with Costa, like, I like—
I slipped a jab, he threw the left hook,
and I cracked him with the left hook
and just felt like I went through them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It just felt like nothing.
So it feels like you're punching
through nothing.
- OK.
- Yeah.
- No. OK. I'm visualizing it again—
- Because you hit ‘em, you feel it, you get the—
- Because, like, I doubt I'm ever gonna knock someone out,
so I want to know what it's actually like.
- Yeah. You feel the impact, but it just feels like nothing really.
Yeah.
- Yeah, OK.
All right, so before we get to fan
questions, I do want to ask you about
working with Paradigm.
- Oh my Gs.
- Because I think it's so cool
that you all like—
- GP.
- Yeah, like you rep so many other champions.
So what is that experience been like?
- Yeah, well Paradigm, I'm glad I brought them on
because I felt like they were
the guys to get me to that next level.
You know, when it comes to, I guess,
dealing with the
media stuff, the promotion,
sponsorships,
endorsements and the pay, cuz,
you know,
they've had, they have,
what's his name, Conor on the team as well.
So he's the highest paid UFC fighter.
Now because of Paradigm,
I'm the second-highest paid UFC fighter.
- That’s fire.
- And, yeah, I'm,
I'm still greedy because I know my worth.
So I want more.
And I know what's been left on the table
and I want to take some more.
- Yeah.
- And also they're helping me
as well in certain aspects to
make sure that the fighters
on the roster as well get some.
But it's not an easy process.
It's just, it's a lengthy process.
But right now,
I'm grateful for the position I'm in.
And thanks to my people at Paradigm.
A special shout out to Tim.
- Special shout out to Tim.
- Tim, he's my, he’s my boy.
So, yeah, special shout out to him as well.
- OK.
I love that. Shout out to Paradigm.
All right, Rocky. Fan questions?
- [Producer:] What do you think Pereira will
bring out of you that other fighters haven’t?
- Pereira, what would he bring out of me?
He's not gonna shy away,
because he already has that in his mind
that he thinks I'm easy
because he's beat me.
So he's not going to shy away. He's
going to actually try and attack me.
I'm going to try to win the fight,
which always brings out the best in me.
When someone tries to fight,
you know, I'm a fighter.
I'm right there trying to fight.
But then when someone's trying to be—
uh, they’re trying to survive,
it makes it harder to take them away.
So, I'm glad
this guy's not going to try to survive.
He's going to try and win. Yeah.
So I'm going to take that away from him.
- OK, I like that. Another one?
- [Producer:] What round are you knocking him out?
- I can't tell you that.
Like I said, I'm saying
less this whole lead up to this fight.
I just—you know what?
Like I said,
I might not even knock him out.
I might literally just f--king jab,
leg kick and just move out the way
and then get a decision-win.
But, hey, stay tuned.
Or I might get knocked out.
Stay tuned. You might find out.
- I would say, I respect that
because it's hard to say
less, like being silent is difficult.
- Trust me, and for me in this position,
like I said, the duality—when
I'm by myself, my people know me,
I chill, I barely say a word,
and we can talk for hours, but now I’ll
spend hours just chilling, saying less.
But when it’s this, I'm a social butterfly.
I can rap, but for me, I just—silence,
say less, say less.
This camp, I'm just like, “Yo, just chill.”
Let him, let him do all the talking.
I'll do my talking
when it's time in the Octagon.
- Nice. Any more?
- [Producer:] OK, this one’s a two-part.
What—do you have any crazy weight-cutting
stories, and what's your favorite meal after you’re done?
- Ooh.
- Yeah, what's
the craziest thing
that you have done to make weight?
So cutting weight.
- [Laughing] Ah, you don't know Tim. But I’m like...
let me pause, pause, pause let me think
if I can say this.
- No, you already have it.
You have to tell us, those are the rules.
Ahh, man. [Lips smacking]
It’s just, ahh, I...
ah, f--k, hold up. F--king hell. [Laughing]
- OK, all this but—you know,
you have to tell us. Like, you can't,
you can't do this pause.
- Oh man, I know, I was trying to—
- I feel like I know so much about you now.
- Yeah! [Laughing]
- What is the crazy thing you did?
- I was trying to—well, back in kickboxing,
back in the day, when I was an amateur,
when I was really young and had no—
I didn't have the fight dietician,
who was the guy that looks after us here
with my meals and whatnot,
I did not have him on deck.
I wasn't in the UFC.
Oh, f--k man. [Laughing]
OK, I erm...
f—k, how do put this?
I busted a nut to make weight.
[Both laughing]
- OK, rewind.
- Let's not go into that story, but that's just...
- No, I'm not going to ask the specifics of that part.
[Adesanya laughing]
But how much does that weigh? I mean...
- You really wanted to know?
- No! I guess,
I'm just like I would never think,
“Oh, this is the thing
to do.”
- So, at the time, I was young,
and I was on that whole no...before a fight. And da, da, da, da.
Before I knew it was a myth.
And, yeah, I just—
and then the few grams came off.
100 grams.
- You made weight.
- Yeah, I made weight [Laughing]
- Wow. This is the lesson of today,
fighters.
- Exclusive! But I wouldn't advise it.
Ey, I was younger back
then. Like, 21, 22.
I didn't know what I was doing
with weight cutting.
And, yeah, that was, er...yeah,
that was something.
- But you made weight.
- I made weight.
I've never missed weight in my life.
- Look at that.
- Knock on wood I never will.
- What do you think is the lesson in that
in that story?
- Well, I wouldn't advise it. I would—
the lesson is just get a proper
dietician and,
you know, and learn how to water load,
get your nutrition right,
so you can make weight without,
you know, doing your thing.
-  [Laughing] I love it.
- F--k.
- So worth telling us, by the way.
- I was trying to, I was trying to...what can I? How can I?
I was like, “Oh f—k!" It was in my head already.
So I was like, “Think of something else.
Think of something else.” I was like, “F--k.
What’s a good story?” But that was already right there.
- I honestly was more interested in the,
like, the weight of that
and how that that worked. OK.
- It was, like, 200 grams or something. But—
- You know,
as much as I wanna end on that
because it's amazing,
is there one more fan question? [Laughing]
- Yeah, we can end on that! [Laughing]
That's the one right there.
- [Producer:] OK, outside of your home country,
where is your favorite place to fight?
- Ooh.
- Outside of his home country, favorite place to fight?
- Well, I'm never fighting in New Zealand again.
I have reasons for that.
But, I mean—
- Are you able to tell us?
- Oh, just the way they treated my boy
Dan Hooker,
who's fighting on this card as well,
when it was COVID times.
They shafted him, the bureaucrats there.
So—but I love New Zealand people,
and the people that support us.
I appreciate
you, and I fight for you guys, too.
I don’t really care
where you're from in the world.
If you f--k with me, I f--k wit you. But
favorite place to fight?
Honestly,
Vegas always has—
it's like, it’s the Mecca. But where I have
fought, my favorite place
where I have fought.
I might say, right now,
off the top Fight Island
when I was COVID times. When I fought UFC
253. Fight Island was cool
because it had a different vibe to it.
And also, in the arena,
it was like f--king handful of people
there, maybe, like, 40 in there
and just working, no crowds, just working,
and the UFC president and whatnot.
Um, yeah.
So Fight Island was probably, in Abu
Dhabi, was probably my favorite place yet
to fight.
- OK, amazing.
And last question,
this is a question from me.
I know you have you've talked a lot about,
you know, being Nigerian, um—
- What's your heritage, do you know?
Well, no, I've done like ancestry.com,
and I was 52 percent Nigerian, but I don't know.
- So there’s something in there, yeah. But you don't know the heritage?
Where were you born.
- I was born in St. Louis,
but I'm from Georgia.
- St. Louis. Missouri?
-Yeah. St. Louis, Missouri.
But I was there for like a year.
- OK, I see. So Georgia.
- Yes.
So you have to say the best place to
get jollof rice in America right now.
- Oh, God.
- And then second part is, I've noticed that
when you say your last name—
- A-de-san-ya.
- You're saying it differently than everyone else.
- Yeah, so, when I was living in China, right,
they really like the way I pronounce
my Mandarin because my language is tonal.
So, you know, everyone says, “Ade-san-ya.”
A-de-san-ya. Everyone tries
to say it as well.
It's like, if you weren't born with
the native tongue to say it, it's hard.
- Yeah.
- But Ade-san-ya—listen. Ade-san-ya.
A-de-san-ya.
Na-na na na. Na na na na.
Na-na na na. Na na na na. Ade-san-ya.
A-de-san-ya.
- Yeah.
- It's a, it's a different tone.
It's kind of like—I'm not from East
Africa, or the people who have the
[Clicking tongue]
I never do it right. Like, they,
when they do the clicks, it's so guttural.
It's like a, [Single clap] like—
-  Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
But I can't do it because I was not born there,
and I didn't grow up with that
native tongue.
So, sometimes people—I just,
I say, Adesanya is fine,
because it's, you know, the phonetic
way of you guys saying it.
But, um, yeah, it's Adesanya.
- I just didn't know if you would like,
you know, for people to say it.
- No, no, no, I understand. Cuz if you could say
Arnold Schwarzenegger, like, you can say, Adesanya.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- But my full name is
Israel Mobolaji Temitayo
Odunayo Oluwafemi Owolabi Adesanya.
Yeah. That’s powerful.
- Wow, that's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- Thank you.
I love that for me, too.
- Yes. Well, you know what? You are a pleasure.
- Yeah, likewise.
I am so happy that we made this work
- Same.
I wasn't expecting this. I just, I did
Luke Thomas, this morning
and then did some work upstairs and then,
yeah, this was cool.
I'm glad.
- Absolutely.
- It was, like, less fight questions.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? I like to chill.
- We care. We care about you.
- [Blowing kisses]
- [Laughing] No, best of luck in your fight.
We will all be watching.
- Thank you so much. I appreciate it. Thank you all.
- We'll all be rooting for you and yeah.
- Mwah.
- Bye.